he is uh keegan michael key he's actor
comedian writer producer
and he is uh emmy-winning actor who is
narrating drafted it's a new docu-series
podcast in association with i heart
radio
tree fort media and clutch sports group
what it does it follows top college
football players as they prepare to
enter the nfl draft
first two episodes launched just last
monday
two new episodes releasing each week he
is the uh
well he's a lions fan too and you the
lions picked up a victory on
on sunday do you want the lions to do
well or like they win when they're not
supposed to win here key
right no i do want them to do well i
i've wanted them to do well since i was
eight years old
but um yeah they were not supposed to
win that game which i which i'm jubilant
about
but i um the thing is that every season
recently the thing that you can hope the
most for is that they play spoiler to
somebody
going into the playoffs that's about as
much as we've been able to uh
that's been that's where we've been
finding our happiness so
uh i do want them to win i i would love
it if we if we were in a
position to not have the third pick um
i'm very excited about our pick this
year
about jeff okuda his first interception
this last weekend which was very
exciting
break it down what's that break it down
here
very early i i love that
but you know when you start to the lions
are one of the great
untold stories they're you know the cubs
ended up winning like you have these
franchises that have won
the lions might be that last great story
in the nfl
i think they are i think i think they
definitely are i wouldn't mind
being i wouldn't i don't even part of me
says
i'm going to be impatient like i'm going
to be childlike and be impatient and say
oh i want the winning to happen
immediately
but god dan would i be able to savor
what if i was 82
you know what i mean you know when you
see those stories
those those news stories there's the old
guy with the walker
and the tears streaming down his face
like i never thought the cleveland
browns well i shouldn't mention the
cleveland browns
but i never we don't want to talk about
something that's completely impossible
but but you know i would love to be i
would i know i didn't that mean
they're not even in the nfc leave them
alone keegan but it would be
it would be great if i could just be
that old man in the chair
you know with like my old ball cap it's
too big for my head going
we did it we you know surrounded by my
grandchildren that whole situation
i i still i was just telling the guys
recreating that story that you told when
you go in that monday and and uh peel
was either
playing madden or watching football or
just somehow heard to brickishaw
ferguson's name
and how it it was such a light bulb
there like
you know i i remember de brika shaw
ferguson at like virginia like i
i'm so accustomed to those names but
here's
you know jordan peele who's not a sports
fan and he's going wait a minute
and then you're a sports fan so you
probably never
looked at this and listened to this and
went oh there's nothing wait
that's funny that's a football name i'm
like what are we talking about here
i think i even said to jordan i said
when he said man how is there a dude
named debrika shaw
ferguson and i said i said wait a minute
first of all
i said that's in the pros jordan we
haven't even touched the tip of the
iceberg
when you get to college the names
and the funny things to his to his
credit to his talent
he didn't even do any research when he
wrote those the rest of those names
he just made them up the blueprint was
depression ferguson
i'm like okay guess if you're gonna use
a blueprint that would be the one
either that you know or a barkhevias
mingo i mean all he needed was to hear
those two names
and he was off to the races i got one
for you uh yeah this guy plays at
kentucky
paulie yeah running back kavacier smoke
his last name is smoke amazing
well i'm okay with smoke crevassier
about crevassier
as in that he must have come out of the
womb a very sophisticated looking
baby you know what i mean
and he's got a brother hennessy oh my of
course
no no he does i was joking about that
but i believe
when i was a kid the big thing was um
that there were there
in my neighborhood there were two kids
named
i'm going to go the exact opposite
direction on this there were two kids
named a
and b johnson they were twins
and their names were a and b and i'm
like you can't
do that to a child
i i i had some rough names that i grew
up with
and that i can't even say them on the
show
oh geez it's off color and
yes but you know you grow up and that's
just the person's name you don't even
think twice about it
and then somebody goes wait you went to
school with somebody named that
right right exactly right and i know you
just kind of think to yourself oh that's
just you know that's
that's uh giorgio giorgio not not the
not the craziest name
i went to school i went to high school
now here's another one
i went to high school um with a
gentleman by the name of ignacio
great name i thought that was great
because it sounded like he should have
been in an old dickens novel
but you just call him iggy or dude iggy
yeah iggy it's
which is like one to me one of the best
nicknames ever you know
it's like also a good detroit nickname
because iggy pops from detroit oh that's
right
and i have to understand i have to put
in i have to talk about at least
two to three uh people who are from
detroit on every interview
yeah did you get in everybody you needed
to get in
i think i got everybody in oh i just
have to say barry sanders i just have to
say it randomly
every time uh he's uh keegan michael key
and uh he's got a new podcast here so
are you working with lebron's people
on this yes clutch the clutch media
people yeah that's that's who
they're one of the producers of uh of
drafted and so
and and um they're also repped by my
agency so we were we were
collaborating working together on this
thing have you hung with lebron before
i haven't i have i have not even had the
pleasure of meeting him yet
so well how did you how did you get
involved in narrating this where
these are guys are going to be drafted
or the process of being drafted
the the producers they came to me and
asked me if it was something i'd be
interested in
and i think they they had already known
that i had an interest in college
football and in pro football
and the draft to me is always you know i
think april's always a great time to
have the draft because it's right in the
midst of all of your
your yearning and longing for the new
football season to start it's so early
but it's it's long enough away from the
super bowl that you're going come on man
it's
with all these other sports now when is
the football coming
and so they they they um they they had
been put together by my agents
with me and uh they knew that i liked it
and i said this
i'm in i'm 100 and i'd love to do this
and it was such a
unique situation because you know the
the this year's draft
took place during a very unprecedented
time and
nobody was in the same room everybody
was in their individual bubbles
but our producers sent uh microphones to
all these players
and they got really honest raw stories
from these guys and a lot of the time
the guys would walk around with their
mics on
sometimes they didn't know the mics were
on so you got
really emotional moments with their
family and their friends and talking to
coaches on the phone it was great it was
great it was really
we got lots of fantastic footage what
else are you working on
right now i'll go ahead no i was going
to say in that mind of yours you're
probably uh
got a million ideas here but how do you
get those ideas then down
into paper and then kind of see a
project through
i am i always i'm like i always work
with a writer
and a a a fellow writer i always have to
i'm a partner person
so i had jordan for years and now um my
wife is my writing partner
and she's brilliant but what happens is
i'll i'll come up with a general idea or
what you do is like when you start
getting into a creative process you'll
finish a creative process
the way that you start a new one is by
what i just call opening up the antenna
so you have to open up the antenna to
notice absolutely everything
and then certain things will spark for
you and then those are the things that
you try to drop in
and i i'm very much kind of a bigger
idea person
and i'll start writing down ideas
writing down themes
and then whoever i'm writing with we
start to come together
so that they can go what about this line
what about that line
and and they kind of helped me hone down
that bigger idea into a more specific
idea
so that's what i did i do i did that
with jordan and do that with l
where i go what about this and then they
go
and then what you do dan is you just
kind of start playing off of each other
so that you just keep distilling down
that bigger idea until it gets to what
you want it to be um
and that's that's always that's been my
process that's been my process i brought
up
to the uh dance that uh i i was watching
a
key and peel and uh you were playing a
doctor
and and peele was the gang leader and
you're
explaining in doctor's terminology
about his mom is sick and she's
overweight and then you know
jordan is firing back like you're
dissing his mom
and he it's like a rap battle going back
and forth
and one of the great walk-off punch
lines of all time that we can't say
but right like it was there ever did all
the episodes
get green lit like did you ever have an
episode uh that somebody says no you
can't do that
no we actually that comedy central was
very liberal about that they allowed us
to do pretty much
everything we wanted the biggest the
funny thing is the biggest
issues we ever had with them was early
on in the process of the
show i would we we we so badly wanted to
do star wars sketches
or like a star wars parody and and then
one of the producers like i don't know
star wars and i'm like
what do you talk about star wars is our
mythology star wars is never
not popular he's like i don't know star
wars right now
should we do star wars like there's only
six star wars movies
right now no you're right you're right
it's not in the zeitgeist
but that was the only thing they ever
fought us on
were these star wars uh scenes but the
thing is we had scenes that we pitched
to comedy central dan
where they were like yep sounds good
don't you
don't you think it's a little i don't
know that's hey go for it man if you
guys want to be on the edge
yeah we were just thought you were gonna
say no okay so i heard you and then you
have to make it then you've got to make
the sketch
um uh so they were they they never
ever pushed on subject matter they were
always like go for it
go forward jordan i remember he had some
trepidation about if you remember the um
slave auction sketch yes he was like i
don't know i just wanted it because it
was kind of an exercise i wanted to see
if i could do something that would make
slavery funny
or i could find a way to do that and
then we pitched it and he got nervous
and then they they green lit it they're
like go ahead and shoot it and he was
like
but you know it turned out to be one of
our i think one of our more memorable
sketches at the end of the day oh didn't
you have the uh
kind of a rap battle between was it
malcolm x
and martin luther king yeah and you're
trying to get the crowd on your side
here
by saying shocking things there and you
know martin luther king's doing it his
way and then malcolm x is doing it his
way and then
yeah and then all of a sudden the next
thing i'm doing the worm
[Laughter]
by the way little tidbit first time i'd
ever done the worm
yeah or attempted to do the work i just
dropped to the ground i'm just just
trying to outdo jordan
and then the director goes cut and i get
up i go all right
the worst time i've ever done that in my
life wanted to know we have some ice
um are you working on movies um
doing a tv show right or like a limited
series right now for apple
apple plus uh i'm in vancouver right now
and um
it's uh it's a musical this is actually
by the way my third musical
um my third musical in the last year
uh i've done two other that i'm not i'm
not allowed to talk about right now but
but uh i i did you know i did like a lot
of kids who are actors or drama geeks
you grow up you do musical theater in
high school
and i did that for years and i used to
sing in a band
and um somebody came to me and said
would you like to do this musical a year
and a half ago and i was like
yeah that sounds good i've been sung in
a while so that's kind of been a thing
i've been doing recently which has been
a lot of fun
how often do you sing like i sing
i sing a lot actually i sing i i sing um
but you were in a band what kind of band
were you in it was it was
it was the night it was the early 90s
and it was like a cover i was in a cover
band
i used to perform at grounds coffee
house
on the campus of the university of
detroit mercy my alma mater
and we'd go to grounds coffee house and
sing you know like under the bridge by
red hot chili peppers
and i used to wear i used to wear i wore
a t-shirt that i can't say with the name
what the words were on the t-shirt but i
you know dan that whole deal
like i wore a flannel shirt tied around
my waist but i never
actually wore the shirt just forward
remember in the night number
oh yeah any better oh yeah the combat
boots and the flannel shirt
but you don't wear the flannel shirt you
just have it there
just in case you know rainy seattle yeah
in case your your wife or girlfriend
needs uh you know she's cold
right there i was in a i was in a two
bands
but it was like parliament funkadelic
we're both bands
same guys two different names so one one
band was called
uh free love lemonade and the other band
the other band was called trip master
monkey those were the names of course
of course what else 1992. did you ever
meet you know george clinton
i've i never met him i and i've always
the the i'm going to do it again the
first
two albums the first two or three albums
that funkadelic ever
released were made in detroit they were
recorded in detroit
and um but i always wanted to meet him
uh and i never have i've seen him a
concert a few times but i've never met
him
yeah a little atomic dog you know you
should be oh yeah atomic dog
george george clinton said um what did
he say he was on a um interview one time
and he said someone said to them do you
think that uh do you believe that um
any kind of illicit drug like lsd um
influenced your uh your career your
music
george clinton said hey man i think i
influenced lsd
that is great isn't there a line in that
song where
he goes chase the cat like it's just
why must i be like that why must i chase
the cat
ain't nothing but the dog in me it's
just
like great to talk to you man have fun
in vancouver good luck with uh the
podcast there and great to connect with
you again
you too dan always a pleasure thank you
mike that's a keegan michael key
um the podcast by the way it's a it's
called drafted a new docu-series podcast
in association with i heart radio
tree fort media clutch sports group
follows college players
as they prepare to enter the nfl draft
the first two episodes launched on
monday
two new episodes release uh each week